[Applause]
we listen to the next clip as well now
and just before we get some reaction
from you what my boys did I couldn't I
beg you do not play a game with us
you can't the module of magnet I beg you
do not tell us lies okay she's gonna
back the mother they get it I beg you do
not waste our time I'm sick him tige
Smith first of all that gentleman
upstairs at the council meeting saying
we don't want you you're not listening
your response to that what actions speak
louder than words as far as I'm
concerned I've obviously taking this
role on and my specific grief is to deal
with Grenville North Kensington and the
provision of housing and we have a lot
of people in hotels in a desperate
situation and my priorities to inject
them out of those hotels and get them
into accommodation given what that man
was saying that they don't want you they
don't want the team that's insert you
that's quite clear from that meeting
last night what I believe I am the right
man to do that I worked as part of a
team I mean the the the anger that was
expressed at last night's council
meeting is no different to all the other
meetings were attended over the last
month in North Kensington on the second
day after the the fire and the in the
Westway Center
you know our staff were being told to
take off all their badges as were other
people from the NHS and clearly there's
a tremendous amount of anger directed
not just justifiably towards the the
Kensington Chelsea council but also
wider in terms of established there's a
lot of anger there but I
the best way of addressing now is to
build trust you know we're coming from
the basement on that one and I recognize
that but to build trust by delivering
what people need and that second clip
there I mean we weren't just seeing
anger last night where we were seeing
raw emotion people who had traumatized
who are still grieving and she was
saying please don't play games with us
we want the truth
do you think that they're getting the
truth what the truth comes from lots of
different lots and lots of questions I
mean there are lot of questions relating
to the building itself and the events
that lead up of the choir that's all
part of the inquiries part of the
criminal investigation and its end and
it's very difficult to ask there were
questions last night and regarding the
tower itself and what's going to happen
when a tower and clearly long term and
that's going to be very much the
decision as far as the local community
is concerned you know but this is not of
these aren't things that the council can
answer these are things that obviously
we can request are answers from the
police DVI or DVI economy can conducting
that investigation you know they're the
ones that obviously give the answers but
understandably where people aren't
getting Alice's they're getting
incredibly upset and incredibly angry
and you know you talk about housing that
being your area of expertise and have a
listen to this woman what do you make of
this since the fire I move for hotels
and I don't know now where I'm still
gonna be stay I didn't go to walk I'm
confused I don't know where I'm going or
where I'm what I'm doing some reaction
to that well my reaction is we have to
remove at the pace of the people as they
we've made 300 offers we've had 17
acceptances and that's a reflection of
the fact that it's a very delicate
situation of finding housing which is
appropriate to people I mean what was
lost in the Malay last night was an
announcement that we bought another 31
units that's 99 units that we bought in
the last month committing the reserves
that we have which is important when
obviously to do that but that's only 99
we have 151 households from the ground
floor tower and the immediate walkway
that were obviously having to provide
permanent alternative accommodation that
suits their needs not everybody wants to
be in in North Canton for understandable
reasons so again that's something which
we have we have to factor in
but beyond 151 we have all the blocks
around I mean we've got 358 years the
scale of this is incredibly large and
it's something that needs to be done as
quickly as possible um yesterday
Elizabeth announced the long term target
of doing for headland houses have looked
I had a quick look of all the projects
we have in progress and on the sites
available and I believe that is
something that is achievable but that's
not going to deal with the lady who
you've just shown in the clip she's in a
hotel you know and it's desperate she's
been in hotel for a month and so we can
only offer offer and find a solution
that is right for her you know but we're
not going to force her into that
decision quite right we wouldn't do that
you know you talk about this being a
delicate situation and we've had a local
resident on the program this morning
saying that at the meeting last night he
saw members of the council rolling their
eyes alders looking at their phone as if
they were bored and I just want to play
you a clip here now of council at Mattie
Palmer and just have a watch of his lips
and what he's mouthing
[Music]
so just to be clear the counselor
Matthew Palmer is mouthing don't let
them in do not do not let them in and he
repeats it many times and do you think
that's the correct way to handle the
meeting last night oh well I mean
yesterday's meeting we I mean we have a
small council chamber I mean we were
being directed by the police who advised
us that we had 800 people turning up to
the meeting you know we wanted to have
the maximum number of people there and
we linked obviously in terms of the
Great Hall and to outside to make sure
and let into the to the chamber as many
people you know but again only a month
ago we had in that same chamber we had
people storming in and and if you had
taken the cameras out through those
doors where you sue to the left and the
mayors changing you will see that that
was smashed up so we have a lot of fear
and concern obviously for we have a lot
of that fear of concern within the
building we obviously have a concern for
the safety of people coming in and and
the security people that were there were
obviously there to give priority to the
to the victims and the speakers and the
prep and a selection of the people who
were there to protest justice for
Grenville quite rightly they had to come
in and get their way so orchestration
was quite difficult yesterday and I
acknowledged it was difficult what we
have done and we're not hiding from this
we're now saying we can have eight
council meetings we've we've increased
that number so we will have this that we
will continue the policy of being open
and allow people to come in and speak
and just to be clear and I'm gonna push
you on this because I do think it is
important there'll be people who are
watching that clip and seeing that
counselor saying do not let them in who
feel very very uncomfortable with that
and I just want to make sure that you
think that was the right thing to do I
don't think it's the right thing to make
that comment I don't think it was the
right thing to to bar people coming in
but as I stress that the the security
arrangements were being handled in
conjunction with the police this isn't
the council turning around saying don't
let these people in we welcome the
people kami and we have three and a half
hours of that council meeting dedicated
to allowing people to speak which is not
something we've ever done before to
counsel me
but that is really reflecting and that
was an initiative of the new leader
Elizabeth to ensure that people are
heard so in terms of orchestrating
future meetings it's always very
difficult you know in futures done I've
seen this from the meetings in North
Kensington because you have a lot of
victims who will come who won't want to
have the media there who want to have a
quiet you know meeting and be able to
answer questions without it being being
dominated by other people so it is
reaching that balance and yes I think it
was the events of last night
our referee we will look at that and we
will ensure that next council meeting we
give the widest opportunity to people to
come